- I've talked to Trump maybe
more recently than ever.
Same guy, but I
don't agree with him.
I don't agree with the pulling
out of our troops outta Syria
and abandoning the Kurds.
I don't agree with the down way
we're pulling out of
Afghanistan at the time,
I didn't want 5,000 troops,
but I thought 1200 was fine.
I disagree with
them on a few things
and he didn't like that,
but I think he respected it.
But the audience goes crazy,
especially early
when you disagree
with what the president's
doing that you know,
General Mattis is
not a bad General.
It's not a good thing to say
I like people that
didn't get captured.
Doesn't mean I hate Trump,
but I am not going
to pretend to saying
that about John
McCain was right.
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the co-anchor
of Fox & Friends,
the host of the Brian
Kilmeade radio show,
the host of One
Nation on Fox News
and a New York Times bestselling
author, Brian Kilmeade.
Brian, finally, welcome
to the Ruben Report.
- Yeah, nice to see you, Dave.
- That is quite a resume.
You know, sometimes
we bring on guests,
it could be a kind of
thin resume. I gotta
get to it easily,
but you do a lot of stuff.
And I think that's point
being driven home by the fact
that I think you're
standing right now,
like you gotta go in a second.
- Right. No, I prefer
the standing desk.
And I know you talk about
these guys with thin resume's,
it's because you're talking
about Joe Rogan, right?
That guy doesn't really do much
and you have trouble finding
a reason to interview him.
- Yes, he's not
doing much out there,
but you have like 87 shows.
People see you all the time.
You also, you're on
Gutfeld all the time.
You're guest hosting
on every other show.
- With you.
- Yeah, we're doing the show
together, all that good stuff.
But I'm curious,
I actually don't
know a ton about you
beyond your Fox life.
I was curious just a little
bit about like history,
childhood growing up,
what got you into this,
this crazy media situation?
- So Dave, it's really
none of your business,
so I just wish you'd back off
and stop the personal questions.
- Sorry man,
This is Barbara Walters?
I mean, what's going on here?
- We wanna make you cry by the
end of this thing, you know?
- Yes, I am.
I am crying inside.
Basically, my big
thing was growing up,
I was a big time soccer player.
Wanted to be great, wasn't.
My whole family, my whole town.
Went to college, played soccer
at Post, but the whole time,
by the time I got to
college, it was pretty clear.
Not only wasn't
there a pro league,
but I wasn't nearly
in the conversation
with anything like that,
although all my friends were,
which is certainly humbling.
And then I always
wanted to do radio, TV,
really since ninth grade.
And that's what I was
always pushing for,
whether it was at the
campus radio station
or interning at NBC.
Doing the history of
late night television
as my senior project.
I've got an interview
with Letterman
when I was still in college.
Not for a job, but actually
for the air, for radio.
- Oh wow.
- And that's what I wanted
to do and I went right,
took all that momentum
and all that drive
and went right to Bennigan's
where I kept waitering
right after college trying
to get that first job.
So I started my own local
show, got a bunch of sponsors,
got a limo deal,
got a clothing deal.
- Wow.
- Got a catering deal, got
a little sponsor money,
built a set and realized,
because in our business
it was pre podcast days,
if you don't have a tape
you're not gonna get a job.
They don't care about
your school, your grades.
So I was able to get a tape
then work on my accent,
started doing
standup along the way
because that'll
be an opportunity
that no one could deny you.
There's always a
stage to go up on,
even if it's a terrible one
in the middle of a
diner at 5:00 PM.
- Yep.
So it'd be a great
way to get composure,
be able to react to an audience.
And then went out to LA and
got a job at a TV station
doing all sports radio on the
weekends and doing standup.
Probably making
$27,000 all in all.
You know, I remember
I was getting paid
596 every two
weeks to work in TV
at which was these,
what happens is these,
the home shopping network
bought a bunch of stations
so they can get on cable
and to have just get on,
they had to form their
own news service.
So I'd go in there with one
news director and two people
and we'd do all the copy,
do all the interviews,
do all the booking. So it was
a great way to get experience.
And then got a job back here
in New York for $35,000 a year
doing sports and I was doing
that and was great to be home.
The only thing bad about it,
after three months I got fired.
The new guy they hired
was actually the anchor
masquerading as
the news director.
The news director
became the sports guy.
And then I'm out of a
job and then was able
to claw my way
back into Newsport
get an interview with Fox
in 96, started filling in.
And I've been able to hold
onto the job ever since.
I got extremely
lucky after 12 years.
- Yeah, that's what
they always say.
It's an overnight success.
But where the hell were
you for those first?
- Yeah.
- You know, 12, 15, 20 years.
Do you miss a little
bit of that kind of,
I didn't realize
that you had started
a bunch of things
yourself and all that
and as you said
before podcasting.
Do you miss a little
of that grind?
Because you're in a pretty
smooth system right now.
Whenever I do anything with Fox
and I saw you at
the Patriot Awards,
it's like Fox just does
a nice job of programming
and it's good and it works.
- Yeah.
- And it's, yeah.
Do you miss any of
that? The messiness?
- Well a couple of things that
I was able to do, you know,
like the scramble where
you're out on your own
like you were doing,
when you go and do speaking
events and you get people there.
I have a little of
that with the books.
So when the books come out,
it's up to us to chart
something that Fox is gonna okay
that allows us to go do
personal appearances.
And you try to get out
there to different theaters
or different events, even
breweries and you try to get
500 people there to
do a book signing.
Or you go to a theater
and you try to get
between 500 and
1200 people there.
And I'll talk about
all my books at once.
So that's a little of the
grind and the entrepreneurship.
But within the one thing in
Fox, I think you picked up,
you know, Fox &
Friends is a machine.
But within those interviews,
if I have Dave Rubin one-on one,
I do what I want and I
talk to the producers.
If I have, you know,
Trey Gowdy has a book out
or Mike Pompeo has a book out,
you know, confer
with the producers.
But pretty much you
do what you want.
But that's a machine.
Like Fox & Friends is
a logo for a reason.
It's gonna be successful
with or without the talent,
no matter who it is,
they'll get the
right people in there
because they know
exactly what they want.
But the radio show I feel as
though within that three hours
I could do what I want.
You know, there's people that
we can't book 'cause it's
you know, I'm not gonna see if
Anderson Cooper's available,
you know, the rivals.
But for the most part
you do what you want.
And then on the weekend show,
I really feel like the Saturday
show at 8:00 Eastern is,
it's kind of my thing
with great producers
and everyone collaborates.
So within this great machine,
the New York Yankees,
before anyone knew they
were the New York Yankees,
you can be yourself.
So that's the
grind a little bit.
And I just feel so
relieved every day.
So Dave, we meet so
many talented people
that don't have great jobs,
even though they're great.
So a lot of it is opportunity.
And the only thing I'm
gonna give myself credit for
is knowing how great this
opportunity was and not thinking
there was something
the grass was greener.
'Cause after those 12 years
and talking to people
while I'm here,
I know that grass
is not greener.
- You know, it's interesting
because, you know,
I feel like I know you pretty
well a little bit off camera
but mostly on camera
and through radio
and all that kind of stuff.
And we've been doing
this for 8 or 10 minutes,
you haven't said
anything about politics.
And I wonder do you consider
yourself really like
a political animal or
more of a TV animal?
- I mean, if you ask
me, Brian format a show,
you don't have to, you
know, Fox just wants a show.
I love the politics of it.
I was glad to leave sports.
Like I like busy.
You know, it's good
to like a team again.
When you do sports, I don't
know how the other people feel,
but after a while it was a job.
I wasn't really
enjoying going to games.
- Yeah.
- Hey, the Mets are
playing seven 30 tonight,
you can go cover the game.
Like, aren't you a Met fan?
I'm like, yeah, but you know,
I don't really need to
go deal with the traffic.
Go back and forth. It
took the fun out of it.
So, but I love
doing the politics.
I love it because it's a
lot like sports as you know.
What's the strategy?
What are you gonna
do to support it?
you know, so instead of fans,
you got money to
support the candidate
and then you have the issues
and besides the issues,
what are you gonna do
to get out the vote?
There's so many different
elements that I'm into.
So you have these
great candidates
but couldn't get
their message out.
Great candidates that
couldn't get any support.
And then the
phenomenon of Trump,
which no one's ever
gonna figure out.
Whether you love
him or hate him,
no one's ever seen
anything like this.
And that to me,
to be able to go talk to
Trump and get a chance
to meet these
people and you know,
and get a chance to interact
with people that make decisions
that affect the
future of a country.
To me, I love that stuff.
I mean, I love foreign
policy the most.
To me, I love if like
when Pompeo comes in
and Condoleezza Rice comes
in or any president comes in,
vice president and I love
diving into relationships.
What's Erdoan like?
You know, what's going
on with the tanks?
What do you mean Germany
doesn't wanna get...
What's so good about
the Leopard tank?
Why can't we...
Oh you need jet fuel for the
Abrams. So I love that stuff.
So I think maybe I thought my
easiest way in with sports,
but my sustainability I
think is I'm so into it.
Like I can't wait to open up
the notes from Fox & Friends
at 3:00 in the morning and
they have every major thing
that happened and
all the sound bites
that stood out from
all the nighttime shows
and some of the daytime shows.
I can't wait to kind of file
that together and assemble,
help assemble the radio show
and give my pitches
for the TV show.
So I love that stuff.
You know, it's funny,
you'll appreciate this.
I wanted when I was in college
to be a SportsCenter anchor.
That's what I thought
I was gonna be,
you know, that's when...
- I can see that.
- That's when, you know,
it was the big show with Keith
Olbermann and Dan Patrick.
Olbermann obviously
went completely insane.
But that's what I wanted to do.
I guess I didn't quite do
that, but just like you,
I kind of did something similar.
But first, you're saying
you're a Mets fan.
Now we're of a similar
age so the question is,
and I'm from New York too.
Where were you on
game six, 1986?
You have to remember.
- Yes.
Game six,
I was literally at Bennigan's
and I did the daytime shift
and we stood there and
we roped off an area,
still wearing my khaki
shorts and my collared shirt
and we stood there
and watched it
and then I was able
to go to game seven.
- You were at game seven?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- And guess how we got in?
Pre 9/11.
Not proud of this, but I
am kind of, we snuck in.
We waited for the big crowd
and we went in between
the turnstiles.
- Wow.
- And I was able to
get into the stadium
and sit on the steps and
watch it. How crazy is that?
- Man, I mean they would never
let that fly these days, but.
- Oh no, you'd be arrested.
Absolutely.
- Yeah, I know game game six.
- And maybe we'll find out
if they have cable in prison.
- I was in Syosset, Long Island.
I was 10 years old having a
sleepover with my buddy John.
I will never forget that ball
going right through
Buckner's legs
and the rest is
history as they say.
- Right, you thought that
we'd have a championship
in 87 and then 88 and then 90.
But who knew they were
doing all types of drugs
and hated each other's
guts and womanizing.
I remember one time Dwight
Gooden came into Bennigan's
'cause it's very close, it's
on the way to the stadium.
And he sat by
himself, by himself
and had three Long
Island iced tea's.
Now he wasn't pitching but
they had a game that night.
You don't drink a
Long Island iced tea
unless you wanna be drunk.
And I'm like, wait a second,
why would you wanna be
drunk and watch a game?
Clearly there was an issue
there and we watched these guys
go in and outta Smithers
for a few years.
That was educational.
- Right, exactly.
For those that don't understand
the Long Island iced tea
basically has every
liquor known to man.
- About five liquors.
- Yeah, if you're
drinking three of those,
you're in trouble.
Let me ask you something.
You mentioned the Trump thing
and how that kind of flipped
everything on its head.
What was that like kind
of going from, you know,
you're doing Fox & Friends,
you're doing the morning show,
all that stuff and
things are kind of normal
or at least old school the
way we thought politics was
then everything just
kind of get blown apart
and now we're in whatever
it is we're in now,
this kind of post-Trump, I don't
even mean that politically,
but just where media has just
been completely blown apart.
- Well no, he did
destroy every network
and he tries to destroy us.
Thankfully he hasn't.
Because they built something
sustainable at Fox,
it's gonna withstand
any candidate.
Even though, you know,
after the election, the fact
that we said the other guy won,
he tried to blow us up and it
definitely hurt the ratings.
What was it like I?
I said to myself the whole time,
why can't he win?
I go, I don't get it.
And when I saw him
come to the debate
and do the opposition research
on everyone on that stage
and go after the
leader first, Jeb,
I go, this guy's into winning.
I mean this guy is
gonna win. Why cant he?
And then to be on CNN
the next day on a phoner,
MSNBC the next day on a phoner.
I watched him dominate
the media cycle.
But what people don't appreciate
is that politicians don't
answer the question.
He was the first in a long time
to almost answer every question.
McCain was very, Barry
Goldwater they say,
and I read his books was
very brusque, you know,
and very direct.
McCain was kind of
direct, you know,
they'd write that Harry
Truman was direct.
But Trump would take everything,
literally take everything.
He did it on our show for eight
years minimum once a week.
And all he was, he'd call
up and go, what's going on?
He'd say we'd give
him three topics.
Very rare for him to say, I
don't wanna talk about that.
And I'm saying, that's
a guy that doesn't care.
But now he's
running for election
and he had the same attitude.
So he ratcheted up
the game for everyone.
If you've given out
wrote lines like you know
the same catchphrase you weren't
gonna work against Trump.
So I think he changed that.
Put everyone on the defensive.
You know, Hillary Clinton still
doesn't know what hit her.
Neither does Jeb Bush
know what hit him.
I was with Jeb Bush last month
and I still think to a degree,
I like him too.
He's a great person with
you voted from or not,
he's still rattled.
So we've never seen anything
like Trump or since.
And I don't think
being a bully is it,
it's not being a bully.
There's something about the
directness where he's a rich guy
his whole life,
but yet most of the people
that like him aren't rich
and never will be.
So I've never seen it anything
like, and you could say,
well he is rich.
Well the rich people
don't like him.
If you talk to rich
successful people,
they didn't want
any part of Trump.
They go, cause rich
successful people
aren't that outgoing and brash
and braggadocio in the
way he'd handled things.
They go, we're not like that.
We have more money than Trump.
And so he connected with a
whole part of the audience
no one expected.
- And they certainly don't eat
steak well done with ketchup.
That seems to be the main issue.
- Right. I did not know, does
he have ketchup on his steak?
- Oh yeah.
Steak well done with ketchup.
That's the thing that
he's doing at Mar-a-Lago
or wherever else he's
eating these days.
You mentioned the thing
about how he sort of tried
to burn the place down or he
was angry at Fox over things.
Do you worry about
that sometimes?
- Still is.
- Because it's
interesting, I find on Fox
there is a plurality
of opinion, you know,
Tucker always bringing
on people to argue with
and that really isn't happening
on the other cable channels.
You know, they'll bring in sort
of like a fake conservative
to basically agree with them.
But are you worried at times
when you guys are doing
the shows that, you know,
a certain segment of your
audience might be angry
at you at this or you
gotta get them back
or all of that kind of stuff?
- Well Dave, I'll tell
you, I go on Truth Social.
- Yeah.
- By the way, I've
talked to Trump
maybe more recently
than ever, same guy,
but I don't agree with him.
I don't agree with the pulling
out of our troops outta Syria
and abandoning the Kurds.
I don't agree with the down way
we're pulling out of
Afghanistan at the time.
I didn't want 5,000 troops,
but I thought 1200 was fine.
I disagree with him on a few
things and he didn't like that.
But I think he respected it.
But the audience goes crazy,
especially early
when you disagree
with what the president's
doing that you know,
General Mattis is
not a bad General.
It's not a good thing to say
I like people that
didn't get captured.
Doesn't mean I hate Trump,
but I am not going
to pretend to saying
that about John
McCain was right.
And the whole audience
will go crazy.
I go on Truth Social
just to, you know,
I'll put something up
there once in a while
or I'll cut and paste
my show's coming up.
50% of the comments
are negative to me
because if you say
anything against Trump,
but who in your life do you
agree with 100% of the time?
And you're not lying.
- Not even myself.
- Right. Yeah. You evolve.
The thing good's cool about Fox
is they never tell
you what to say.
You get your own research,
got your own brain room.
I will tell you I am all for
whatever it takes for Ukraine.
Maybe you are not, I
know Tucker is not.
- Yeah.
- I don't think Laura
is not sure about Sean,
but I don't think it matters.
No one said to me
agree with Tucker
and Tucker's certainly
not checking with me.
But he has insightful things
to say to back up what he says.
So that's called a debate.
That's called I watched
four hours of Fox
and I learned a couple of
sides of a debate, you know,
and it's not no one's personal.
I hope Tucker's not mad at me
by vehemently disagree
about Ukraine, so.
- Well my guess is he,
my guess is he's not mad at
you and you guys still manage,
at least at the TV level,
it seems like everyone
kind of likes each other.
I've been on Gutfeld with
you where Tucker will call in
or you know, when they do the
transitions between shows,
you guys are messing around.
Last time I saw you, I mean
Gutfeld was hitting you hard
and you were going
right back at him.
It's all done in fun and
that's very different
than what goes on on
the other channels.
Like when Lemon used to
have to hand it off to Cuomo
or whichever which way it
was and it was like, man,
you guys really hate each other.
- Well a couple of things,
Cuomo and Don Lemon were best
friends, you're my buddy.
And the minute Cuomo started
blowing up, Don Lemon's like,
why is he still here?
- Yep.
So that is like, that's
the problem with CNN.
They're not real.
That's not real. Whatever
it is, it's real.
Like, so if you have a
disagreement on the five,
the producers wanna make
sure it doesn't get personal,
it keeps it on the issues.
But I'm telling you, I go,
I'm gonna do the
five on Thursday,
I did the five last Thursday.
You disagree with
Geraldo, whatever.
No one's saying
you don't disagree.
- Right.
- And that's just it.
You know what I think it is,
Dave, you do the same thing.
It's this slice of life.
So you go in there
and you might argue
with your best friend sometimes,
but the thing is you
are responsibility
to do, is research.
And if you know the
players, make the call.
And if you could
text somebody to say,
what were you thinking about
on that gun legislation?
And Senator John Cornyn
got back to me, he said,
"Well Brian, let me tell you
exactly what I'm thinking.
Let me tell you what
my red line is."
So when I go sit on
that couch, I'll say,
I'll either say it directly
unless they tell me to.
I'll say, Senator John
Cornyn view is this.
When I sit on, I'll
have my own opinion,
but I'll do my own research.
So that's called
hustle mistakes.
So if I end up being
wrong about something,
it's not because I'm winging it.
And I think most anchors
here are like that.
I mean look at Greg,
you realize to come up
with those opinions,
how well read he has
to be on those issues.
And then knowing that
he's watching the show,
watching the channel all
week and he is going, okay,
everyone's saying
the same thing,
I gotta be different and I
gotta offer that at 11 o'clock.
Whether it's at the
5 or 11, you know,
when he tapes at 6:30.
So I just think that people
understand here it's like having
a paper due every day on
four different topics.
- All that being said,
does Geraldo believe some
of this stuff? Come on.
- Absolutely. Yeah.
I mean he has a way of
being controversial.
But the other day he
hopped on and just said
about the classified
documents in Biden's place,
said nobody cares.
It's not a big deal.
Of course people care, you
know, how could you say that?
I know you might think
it's not gonna solve
the economic problems,
but you think about the
hypocrisy, the way he took it,
how the fact that he has
these classified documents
where they'll put
a marine in jail.
- Yeah.
But the president
can have 35 documents
and you can raid the
former president's house
but ask permission on his.
Don't tell me that's not
an unbelievable story,
but that's how he feels.
There's one thing about Geraldo,
he's got so much practical
firsthand experience
and he also fundamentally
wants people to get along.
I think that he
looks at his life,
he experienced more in 10 years
than I will in 10 lifetimes.
And I think at this
point in his life,
he wants everyone to come
together. But it's impossible.
- Yeah. It's just not,
it's not a reality.
Let me me ask you
something else.
So off politics
and TV for a sec.
You guys are in New York.
I grew up in New York,
lived in Manhattan
most of my adult life.
When I go back to New York,
it is not the same
New York anymore.
You know where you
guys are Midtown-ish,
you don't see a lot of
business people anymore.
It seems like it's kind of
barren and a lot of barricades.
What do you think's going
on over there do you think?
Did you think that
Adams maybe was gonna be
a little bit better
than de Blasio?
Like what's the state
of the city right now?
- I think Adams is 50%, maybe
70% better than de Blasio.
Number one. he cares.
Number two is,
I think that it is
definitely dangerous
and the main reason is not only
do we not have enough cops,
none of them have
been empowered.
The qualified
immunity is not there.
They're not making the
small arrests, shoplifting.
You basically can shoplift now.
- [Dave] Yep.
- And if I'm a small
business owner,
you are now in bodega's
locking the stuff down.
This is totally fixable.
It's not that gangs have
taken over New York.
Criminals have.
The same 300 commit something
like the same 30,000 crimes.
It's all fixable.
But the problem is Albany.
Albany's a super
majority to the left
and they don't have
to deal with the crime
and the danger that Adam Klotz
our a meteorologist dealt with.
- [Dave] Yeah. Yeah.
- Over the weekend.
Watch a guy get beat up,
you step in and you get beat
up by eight guys and the guys
that get caught don't
even get detained.
That's the problem.
There's no hell to pay for
the hell they're causing.
But I do think it's
a little bit better.
- But why is that
an Albany thing
and not directly a city thing
related to Adams and what
he's doing with the police.
- Because he can't reverse
the no cash bail law
and the judges
have no discretion
on if they can prosecute or not.
So you come in, if
it's a certain crime,
I don't care what you did,
you're out on your own.
You gotta appear again at
a certain amount of time.
So everything's knocked down.
Their trying to
close Rikers Island
so there's nowhere
to put people.
And you literally have
somebody who was arrested,
the person who was arrested
breaking into Al Pacino's house
was arrested something like
37 times for break-ins.
I mean that person
would've been twice,
maybe once they
would've gone away.
So if you're a cop,
really, I gotta worry about
if I see somebody who
might be a minority
and I'm a white guy and I
see something going on there
and I see all the
iPhones rolling,
do I wanna risk my life for
$35,000 a year and get sued
and have my whole family
brought through mud?
Unless it's something big, I'm
not gonna get that involved.
But you see how easy it would be
to get everybody in
their front foot again.
But I do think Adam's
at least gets it
and they have a lot of
pride in putting him down.
He went up twice
to Albany to say
you gotta change cash bail law.
They basically told
him don't come back.
So I mean, I do think he cares.
I do still have hope.
- Brian, I got one more for you
because I know
you're a busy guy.
You got 87 shows to do.
Is the rumor true that Greg
Gutfeld will be playing
a munchkin in the
remake of Wizard of Oz?
- Nope. You know why?
Because there's too many others.
If it was a story of
one major munchkin,
- That's right.
ruling over other munchkins,
he would never be a part of
a class or an understudy.
He would never get
best supporting actor.
He would have best leading actor
without any supporting
actor over and over again.
So he'd have to be the
center of attention.
Now Greg's story is
pretty phenomenal.
I was pretty stunned to see,
listened to Joe
Rogan talk about it
'cause the outsider perspective.
Cause I consider you part of us.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I you hope you don't mind.
No, I have my foot in
both worlds. I love it.
I love doing the Fox stuff and
I love doing the Rogan stuff.
It's both worlds that I get
to see and be part of, yeah.
- Right.
And he has no idea like
the people, let's say,
but he's just talking about,
and he's a comedian and he is
saying how the Tonight Show
used to have everything.
There's no doubt why
Gutfeld's most successful.
Is there any doubt?
The reason why he is most
successful is it's normal guys
talking about funny stuff.
Nobody, everybody else is just,
is left comedy and is
now like a new show
with a point of view with
people that can't ask questions.
And Gutfeld is a real show.
You actually laugh.
I watched the cold open of SNL
with Fox Sports and I said,
this is like bad for a
high school variety show.
Are they even rehearsing?
- It's horrible.
- And that's why Greg
deserves a lot of credit
because this is the same show
he's doing on Redeye, you know?
And he just kept doing it,
kept doing it at midnight and
it was getting great ratings
and now he's killing it on
being himself on Saturday.
- It really is that simple.
When we did the Fox Nation
thing a couple weeks ago,
we're about to start
the show, remember?
And Greg turns to me and he
said that he had diarrhea.
And then I was like, I'm gonna
use that during the show.
And then you'd roll with
it and everybody's laughing
and you're giving him crap
about it. No pun intended.
And that's what it's all about.
How are we ending on crap
and Gutfeld? Gimme something.
You're a TV host.
End the show
professionally, please.
- Hey, I'm gonna end
the show professionally.
Let me see, Dave,
you're a deep thinker who also
could do standup and does it.
You do it all.
And somehow you find time
to get a slice of my life.
I am honored to
be asked to be on.
Thanks so much and
promise me next time
and there will be a next time.
Don't bring up Greg Gutfeld.
- There will be no
Gutfeld next time.
Kilmeade, you're a true pro.
I hope to see you in person
soon and now get back to work.
- Syosset misses
you. Go get him.
- If you're looking for
more uncensored opinions
from today's thought leaders,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a wide variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.